okay
let's now get into 2024
joe biden's approval has absolutely
collapsed now i was right there
telling you
when his approval was low but still
historically higher than many presidents
at this point in time i was telling you
that i was saying yeah it's low-ish but
he's still doing better than abcde
presidents at this point in their first
term
you have to go back to the 1940s now to
find a first term president with a lower
approval rating at this point right july
of the second year of his presidency
than joe biden and we're going to get to
those numbers but this is coming at a
time where also
most democrats are saying they don't
want joe biden to run in 2024. now i
don't believe he is going to run in 2024
uh but we're going to get to that in a
moment most democrats don't want biden
in 24 new poll shows
president biden is facing an alarming
level of doubt from inside his own party
64 percent of democratic voters say they
would prefer a new standard bearer in
2024. this is from a new york times
siena college poll voters nationwide
have soured on his leadership giving a
meager 33 job approval rating we'll look
at an average of approval rating in a
moment it's a little bit higher than
that in this particular poll it's at 33
widespread concerns about the economy
and inflation have helped turn the
national mood decidedly dark both on
biden and their trajectory of the nation
more than three-quarters of registered
voters see the u.s moving in the wrong
direction a pervasive sense of pessimism
that spans every corner of the country
every age range every racial group
cities suburbs and rural areas and both
political parties only 13 of american
voters say the nation is on the right
track
now in terms of approval uh joe biden's
approval on average is down to
38.6
this is uh as you can see here the
lowest of his presidency uh he kicked
off his presidency in the mid 50s and
remained there for several months then
started seeing a decline last summer as
the kovid surge happened negative press
about getting out of afghanistan etc
a brief bump towards the end of the year
and then a continued decline
this is really not good and when you
look at historical numbers which 538
allows you to do you now see that joe
biden's approval rating has dipped below
where donald trump's was at this point
in time we're roughly at day 550
where are we roughly five
about 545 of the presidency uh donald
trump had a higher approval rating at
this point barack obama had a higher
approval rating at this point george w
bush had a higher approval rating so did
clinton george h.w bush was doing far
better than than biden is now reagan was
doing better jimmy carter was doing
better although not by much gerald ford
was doing better nixon was doing better
lbj was doing better jfk and eisenhower
you have to go all the way back
to harry truman
in 1946
to find a president that around day
545 was
had a lower approval than joe biden
that's really really bad
i believe it is time for joe biden to
soon say
i will not be running for reelection in
2024 make it public make it clear allow
for anyone on the democratic side
to have time to consider whether they
want to run for president in 2024 decide
whether they want to mount a campaign
and to have a clean open primary for
2024 and i say this for a few reasons
number one i just don't think joe biden
wants to run for reelection that that's
the most important thing it's not about
pushing biden out it's i don't see any
indication that he wants to run he'll be
82
at the time
the language it continues to be that he
intends to run after kamala harris
definitively said he was running the
next day she had to walk it back because
it's very apparent to all of us that
it's not clear that he actually plans to
run that's the primary reason he doesn't
seem to want to run
and it's becoming
politically disadvantageous to democrats
for everybody to kind of have to pretend
like he is going to run i just don't
think he's running secondly his approval
rating is collapsing and whether it's
donald trump or ron desantis or whoever
on the on the republican side
there is going to be a major uphill
battle
um
for the 2024 election and it would seem
prudent and better to
not rush anyone else into having to
decide am i getting in or am i getting
out make it clear i'm not going to be
running for reelection now i'm not
actually saying that biden should
announce this before the midterms it
probably makes sense to wait for the
midterms but it should be done
relatively soon again biden least
popular president at this point in his
first term dating back to harry truman
in the 1940s third
even most democrats don't want joe biden
to run so looking at the pulse of the
party also matters now i am right there
with you in saying that even most of the
those democrats who would rather someone
other than biden
would almost certainly vote for biden if
biden is the nominee but it's not
particularly reassuring when it comes to
the possibility that the right will be
really motivated in 2024 okay sure most
democrats even if they would rather
someone else would still vote for biden
but even if it depresses turnout by a
couple of points i don't know that it's
at the advantage of the democratic party
now there are many good options on the
democratic side but the question becomes
does kamala harris run and if so
do
biden and the dnc attempt to sort of
anoint her the de facto nominee she's
not popular either and she may lose a
contested primary but whatever is going
to happen there should be time so that
democrats don't get caught flat-footed
now let me say one other thing
because i already know some of the
messages that i'm going to get there's a
lot of kind of finger wagging going on
at people who aren't feeling inspired or
confident in biden 2024
the finger wagging should probably
stop
i'm not saying i wouldn't vote for biden
over trump or desantis in 2024 i would
i'm not even saying joe biden hasn't
done some good things he's done many
good things and i've enumerated them
many times i'm saying it would be better
if biden said what most democrats are
thinking and said i'm not running for
reelection we did a great thing here by
taking the country back from trump we
did a b c d e
and i am clearing the way for a spirited
primary where we are going to get i am
sure a great nominee
to go up against what is going to be
a brutally desperate attempt by
republicans to take back the white house
by any means necessary and we know what
some of those means are that's what i
think would be the best
now if you disagree with me or you agree
with me whatever i want to hear from you
let me know what you think find me on
twitter deepakman and we will certainly
follow up on this
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
and it's a sponsor i'm thrilled about
because i sleep on a helix mattress at
home and it's just the perfect mattress
one of the best things about helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do i need which one will be good for me
you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website you tell them your body
type your sleeping position your
back pain issues you might have and they
will pair you with a mattress that will
be perfect for you i took the sleep quiz
the mattress they suggested was exactly
what i needed i often get too hot at
night the mattress keeps me cool it's
not too soft it's not too firm the
texture is right and i've just been
getting way better sleep you only buy a
mattress every decade or so
don't get stuck with something that's
not perfect for you and all helix
mattresses come with a 10-year warranty
and they'll even come to your house and
pick it up within 100 days if you don't
love it but i think you will for a
limited time helix is offering up to 350
off all mattress orders plus two free
pillows at helix sleep dot com slash
pacman it's the biggest discount they've
ever offered the link is down below